Transcription: Maria Ferreira
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour à tous,
je m’appelle Stéphane, j’ai 50 ans.
Je suis marié et je suis papa
de trois enfants.
Jusqu’au mois de septembre 2019,
j’étais un vrai banlieusard parisien.
J’habitais en région parisienne,
mais - vous trouverez pourquoi -
depuis septembre, je suis dans le Jura.
Vous avez remarqué certainement
que mon phrasé est un petit peu lent.
Je bafouille,
je vais bafouiller pendant mon discours.
J’ai été obligé de prendre quelques notes
parce que mon cerveau
ne fonctionne plus comme avant
et je vais vous expliquer pourquoi.
Je vous demanderai aussi d’être indulgent
parce que c’est ma première
prise de parole publique
au sujet de mon handicap.
Je vais continuer
ma présentation de moi-même :
je suis, depuis tout petit,
un vrai passionné de la conquête spatiale,
de l’exploration spatiale,
je suis absolument fasciné
par cette conquête.
Quand j’étais petit,
j’étais fou du feuilleton
« L´Homme qui valait trois milliards ».
Comme lui, je voulais être astronaute,
ce qui a complètement,
on va dire, changé ma vie
parce que depuis que je suis tout petit,
cette passion de l’espace
ne m’a jamais quitté,
elle est toujours là.
Plus j’avançais en âge,
plus je grandissais,
plus cette passion était présente.
J’ai grandi dans les années 70, 80
au moment de la navette spatiale.
Je collectionnais absolument tout ce
qui avait un rapport avec l’espace,
notamment des autographes.
Je suis d’abord un collectionneur,
puis, il y a quelques années,
j’ai décidé de quitter professionnellement
tout ce que je faisais
pour de vivre de ma passion.
C’est-à-dire que j’ai monté une société
qui aide les collectionneurs,
au niveau espace, à rassembler des pièces.
Je fais des recherches
pour les collectionneurs,
je fais des expositions,
je fais des expertises.
Etc.
Je pars du matériel pour des films,
pour des publicités.
Mon introduction peut paraître
un petit peu longue
mais vous comprendrez
que ma passion pour l’espace
a un rapport énorme avec ce que j’ai vécu
et avec ce que
je suis en train de traverser.
Mais, au-delà de collectionner et tout ça,
j’aime beaucoup partager
ma passion.
Je le fais depuis
plusieurs années maintenant :
j’ai un site internet,
au travers des réseaux sociaux
que ça soit Twitter, Facebook.
Je partage les rencontres,
je partage l’actualité spatiale,
je raconte absolument tout ce qui se passe
et principalement au travers
d’objets de collection.
Je me suis lancé il y a
à peu près dix ans.
Jusqu’en septembre 2019,
je vivais de ma passion.
Mais tout ça s’est arrêté brutalement
le 4 septembre 2019.
Je m’en souviens comme si c’était hier.
C’était un mercredi, un mercredi midi.
J’étais à Dijon, à l’hôtel.
Ma femme, qui est militaire,
venait d’être mutée dans la région.
Et pendant qu’elle travaillait
en semaine sur la région,
moi, je cherchais un nouveau logement pour
pouvoir déménager de la région parisienne
pour aller du côté de Dijon.
On est à l’hôtel,
il était midi, je venais
de faire manger mon petit garçon -
mon dernier, qui avait six mois -
lorsque j’ai été pris d’un malaise.
Je me suis senti d’un seul coup
très faible, mal au cœur,
j’avais envie de vomir,
je n’étais vraiment pas bien.
J’ai décidé de remonter dans ma chambre.
Je voulais m’allonger un petit peu,
parce que je me suis dit :
« J’ai mangé quelque chose de pas bon,
qui n’est pas passé. »
J’ai été pris de très forts vomissements,
très violents,
de vertiges énormes.
Je n’étais vraiment pas bien du tout,
et ma tête -
vraiment, je m’en souviens encore -
ma tête, c’est comme si
elle allait exploser, vraiment éclater,
tellement la douleur était intense.
Quand j’étais plus jeune, j’étais pompier.
J’ai été secouriste,
j’ai travaillé pour le SAMU.
L’expérience passée
m’a fait comprendre tout de suite
que ce que j’étais en train de vivre,
ce n’était vraiment pas normal,
c’était vraiment très grave.
Je téléphone au SAMU,
j’ai demandé directement
le médecin régulateur,
j’ai expliqué que je faisais certainement
un accident vasculaire cérébral,
quelque chose peut-être même de plus grave
mais que j’étais certain
qu’il fallait qu’ils m’envoient
une ambulance spécialisée avec un médecin
très, très vite.
Au début, il n’a pas trop voulu m’écouter
puis je me suis un petit peu échauffé,
on va dire énervé,
et finalement, ils m’ont envoyé
une ambulance de réanimation
qui est arrivée dix minutes après.
Et lorsque l’équipe est arrivée,
j’étais déjà vraiment très, très mal.
Ils m’ont transporté directement
en soins intensifs.
On m’a fait un premier IRM
et on a vu qu’une artère de mon cerveau
était en train de fuir.
Elle s’était déchirée et, donc,
je saignais au niveau de la tête.
On a fait un deuxième examen.
On a constaté également que,
en plus de l’artère qui fuitait,
j’avais une artère qui était bouchée.
En fait, j’avais une fuite et un bouchon
au niveau du cerveau
et, en plus, on a découvert en même temps
que j’avais fait deux infarctus,
que j’avais une tension
qui était à plus de 23
et en plus, j’avais des choses
que je ne savais pas à ce moment-là.
Ils ont découvert deux
ou trois autres choses ;
mon état était très inquiétant.
Il y a même un médecin
qui est venu me voir
et qui m’a dit qu’il fallait que -
excusez-moi -
qui m’a dit qu’il fallait
que je me prépare.
Je vais reprendre là.
Pardon, excusez-moi.
Le fait d’y penser,
c’est encore très, très difficile
et c’est la première fois que je parle
vraiment de ce qui m’est arrivé comme ça.
J’ai fait un accident
vasculaire cérébral très grave,
qui m’a laissé d’importantes séquelles.
Il faut savoir qu’en France,
il y a une personne qui fait un AVC
tous les quarts d’heure environ.
C’est un accident
qui est très fréquent, hélas,
et sur ces quatre personnes
qui vont faire un AVC
dans le cours d’une heure,
il y en a une sur quatre
qui va mourir d’emblée
et sur les trois autres qui vont rester,
il y en a deux sur trois
qui ne vont pas passer les cinq ans.
C’est quelque chose
dont on ne parle vraiment pas assez
et quelque chose
qui est vraiment très grave.
Moi, j’ai fait un accident très grave ;
apparemment, d’après les médecins,
j’aurai dû y rester,
je n’aurai pas dû y survivre.
J’ai senti pendant mon arrivée à l’hôpital
une [inaudible] totale m’arriver
de l’oreille jusqu’aux pieds.
Je suis complétement paralysé
du côté gauche.
Ça ne fonctionne pas du tout.
J’ai la moitié de mon corps
qui fonctionne, à droite,
et la moitié gauche
ne fonctionne absolument pas.
En quelques secondes suite à l’AVC,
je ne savais plus du tout marcher.
Je ne savais plus manger.
Je ne savais plus parler, à peine.
Je ne savais plus boire,
je ne savais plus uriner,
qui sont des fonctions naturelles.
Ces choses de tous les jours,
je ne savais plus les faire.
En quelques secondes,
c’était fini pour moi.
J’avais été terrassé par quelque chose
qu’on a tous en commun,
vous et moi, on a tous en commun
la même chose :
j’étais terrassé par mon propre corps.
J’ai passé après
près de six mois à l’hôpital.
157 jours exactement.
J’ai appris à me battre,
à me battre contre moi,
à me battre avec moi,
puisque je me battais
pour cette partie gauche
qui ne marchait absolument pas.
Contrairement aux prévisions,
comme vous voyez, je suis encore là.
Avec une moitié du corps
qui ne marche pas du tout.
Alors, je suis sorti de l’hôpital
maintenant il y a un peu plus d’un an,
et une des choses qui est certaine,
c’est que ma passion pour l’espace
m’a aidé à tenir le cap, à avancer.
Bien sûr, il y a la famille, les enfants,
mais
tous les progrès que j’ai pu faire
pendant ces six mois d’hôpital,
en fait, ces six mois de rééducation,
pour moi, ils étaient naturels.
Je ne me suis jamais senti obligé, forcé
de faire ces efforts.
Pour moi, c’était normal que je les fasse.
Je ne me levais pas,
le matin, en me disant :
« Il faut absolument que je le fasse
pour ma famille, pour les amis. »
Non, pour moi, c’était naturel.
J’avais accepté d’emblée -
je crois que c’est le plus important -
j’avais accepté d’emblée mon état.
D’emblée, j’avais accepté
que mon corps était cassé,
que j’avais des séquelles irréversibles
et que je serais handicapé à vie.
J’avais accepté tout cela d’emblée.
Je n’ai pas eu besoin
de le faire pour la famille, en fait.
Pour moi, c’était naturel.
J’ai eu conscience
très, très vite de mon état.
On va dire dans les quatre, cinq jours
qui ont suivi mon arrivée à l’hôpital,
je savais que je serais handicapé à vie,
que j’aurais des séquelles à vie
et à partir du moment où j’ai accepté,
je peux vous dire, c’était quelque chose
de plus facile à vivre.
Le fait d’accepter,
je n’avais plus à me battre
contre ces séquelles, contre ce handicap
Le fait d’accepter
me permettait de vivre
avec toutes les conséquences
et donc, vivre pleinement
et sereinement avec la famille.
Le fait que j’accepte très vite
m’a permis de faire des choses
qui paraissent -
pour mes amis, pour les proches,
pour les soignants -
qui ont paru extraordinaires,
alors qu’en fait, pour moi,
je vous disais, je ne me forçais pas.
Pour moi, c’était normal.
Mon corps d’avant n’existait plus,
il fallait que je vive
avec mon corps de maintenant.
Et à partir de là,
pour moi, ça a été assez simple,
assez facile.
J’ai pu réapprendre à boire,
j’ai appris un petit peu à marcher.
J’ai réappris à parler -
vous pouvez constater là,
je suis un peu bavard -
même si c’est difficile,
je suis en train de parler.
Cette acceptation,
je pense que je l’ai faite d’emblée
grâce à la famille.
Le fait maintenant de vivre
un peu plus sereinement,
c’est grâce à ma passion.
À savoir que pendant mon hospitalisation,
j’ai commencé un journal de bord,
environ 10 jours après mon AVC,
où, tous les jours, je racontais,
je publiais sur Internet
ce que je ressentais,
ce que je faisais de ma journée
et je peux vous dire
que la tenue de ce journal
m’a énormément aidé,
m’a permis d’accepter mon état,
de mettre des mots
sur ce que je ressentais,
des mots sur ma souffrance, sur mon état,
ça m’a énormément aidé.
Alors oui,
ma vie est très compliquée, très difficile
et très douloureuse
parce que mon corps est entier.
Même s’il n’y a que la moitié qui marche,
l’autre moitié n’est pas morte,
l’autre moitié est toujours présente,
l’autre moitié a toujours des sensations,
elle sent le toucher, le chaud, le froid,
mais de manière très exacerbée.
L’autre moitié
fait toujours ressentir qu’elle est là
alors qu’elle ne fonctionne
absolument plus.
Donc c’est compliqué
et ma passion pour l’espace me permet
d’oublier le côté compliqué de ma vie
pour me concentrer -
pour vivre, en fait, une autre vie.
La vie actuelle, la vivre sereinement.
Ça m’aide vraiment
parce qu’il y a le corps, la douleur,
tous les jours, je le sens.
Au niveau de la famille,
c’est très compliqué aussi.
Donc ma passion me permet
de mieux accepter mon état physique,
l’état de mes proches,
parce que tout est difficile.
Mais ce n’est pas parce que
tout est difficile que c’est impossible.
La preuve, c’est que depuis un an,
je continue de partager sur les réseaux
ma passion pour le spatial.
Je continue
de vivre cette passion,
de la faire vivre en la partageant.
Voilà, il y a le côté très compliqué
de la vie en famille,
mais heureusement qu’il y a cette passion
qui m’aide à surmonter tout le reste
parce que la vie en famille
est très compliquée.
Si moi, j’ai accepté mon état très vite,
ce n’est pas le cas de mes proches,
notamment de mon épouse,
parce que, pour elle aussi,
ça a été un choc,
ça a été brutal, ça a été soudain.
Elle s’est retrouvée,
du jour au lendemain, toute seule,
complètement abandonnée, à tout gérer.
Le fait que je sois encore présent...
fait qu’elle peut...
Lorsqu’un proche part brutalement,
qu’il y a un décès brutal,
le conjoint peut reprocher
certaines choses,
mais comme on n’est plus là,
le reproche s’en va.
Et là, le fait d’être toujours présent
fait que l’acceptation de mon état
est très difficile pour mes proches.
Donc c’est quelque chose
[inaudible] malheureusement.
J’en ai discuté avec d’autres
personnes qui ont des accidents de la vie,
le conjoint a vraiment du mal
à accepter l’état,
c’est ce qui fait que beaucoup de couples
se fracturent, malheureusement,
suite à un accident de la vie.
Heureusement que moi j’ai une passion
qui me permet de ne pas me morfondre
et de penser au côté négatif.
Alors, je sais,
mon propos va vous paraître un peu flou,
mais comme j’ai dit, c’est la première
fois que j’en parle vraiment.
Ce n’est pas évident à expliquer,
ce n’est pas évident à partager.
Mais j’ai accepté cette intervention
parce que je veux
faire prendre conscience
que ce n’est pas parce qu’on est atteint
de séquelles irréversibles,
d’un handicap très profond, très lourd,
que tout est foutu, ce n’est pas vrai -
heureusement.
On peut survivre à cet accident de la vie
et on peut vivre aussi
sereinement, malgré tout.
C’est la passion pour moi,
l’espace m’aide vraiment
à continuer de vivre.
Par exemple, à l’hôpital,
tout le monde savait
que j’étais un passionné de spatial
et tous les soignants, tous les jours,
venaient me rapporter
les dernières nouvelles,
me donner les programmes des émissions
de télé qu’il y avait avec l’espace.
J’ai reçu des dizaines
et des dizaines de lettres de personnes
que je ne connaissais pas,
mais parce je publie
sur Internet mon journal,
elles m’ont apporté leur soutien.
Ça m’a aussi énormément aidé
à tenir le coup, à avancer.
Et donc, à être là aujourd’hui
avec vous,
à partager mon AVC.
Des personnes m’ont fait confiance
bien que j’étais sur mon lit d’hôpital,
on m’a demandé d’écrire
une préface pour un livre,
on m’a demandé des conseils.
J’ai pu constater que
ce n’est pas parce que j’ai été atteint,
physiquement, très fort,
que je ne pouvais plus rien faire.
J’ai continué à faire.
Je pense qu’une des choses,
c’est accepter son état.
Il faut accepter.
Parce que lutter contre les séquelles,
lutter contre son handicap,
ça ne fait pas avancer.
On est toujours là, je suis toujours là
et donc il est hors de question
que je continue de lutter contre moi-même,
que je continue de lutter
contre mon handicap, contre mes séquelles,
parce que je continue de vivre
tout simplement.
Il faut accepter.
Et à partir du moment où on a accepté,
je pense qu’on peut mieux vivre.
Voilà, je vais terminer mon propos.
Prenez soin de vous,
protégez-vous de l’AVC,
renseignez-vous sur les signes
pour pas que ça vous arrive,
que ça arrive à un proche.
Prenez soin de vous.
Merci de m’avoir écouté.